انفجار كبير وقع في شارع الاستقلال الشهير
الذي يتفرع من ساحه التقسيم في وسط مدينه
اسطنبول التركيه الانفجار الذي لم يتضح
سببه حتى الان اسفر عن سته قتلى و 53
جريحا وفقما اعلن حاكم اسطنبول الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان قال ان امراه ضلعه
فيلم الانفجار مشيرا الى ان التحقيقات ما
زالت جاريه ومؤكدا لنا الهجوم نفذ بي
قنبله وفور وقوع الانفجار اخذت الشرطه
التركيه منطقه تقسيم الانفجارين اخر كما
تحدثت وسائل اعلام تركيا عن انتشارا امين
مكثفه في المنطقه من جهته فتح المدعي
العام في اسطنبول تحقيقا في الانفجار
مرجحا انه عمليه ارهابيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كان هناك تفجير في شارع الاستقلال ووقع
قتلى وجرحى اتمنى الشفاء العاجل لهم وتم
نقل الضحايا الى المشافي وسنكشف القائمين
على التفجير وسينالون عقابهم في اسرع وقت
الارهاب
والعناصر التي تحاول النيل من الوحده
التركيه لن تحقق طموحها وسينال المجرمون
عقابهم
تلفزيون الجديد
الى هذا الملف واسم حالي ان ابدا من
اسطنبول معك سيد فائق سيد فائق في الوقت
في الواقعه دلالات الوقت مهم جدا
خاصه في مرحله انت تعلم بان هذه النهايه
سنه هناك عطل مدرسيه هناك كذلك فتره اعياد
وهناك اجازات البعض يستغلها للسفر اسطنبول
وجهها من الوجهات السياحيه او من الوجهات
همم فمن يريد ان يحصد اكثر عدد من الارواح
للاسف هذه الفتره مهمه ولكن من بوابه
الحسابات السياسيه ومن بوابه تركيا كم همم
طرف مهم في المعادلات الدوليه لماذا هذا
الوقت مهم من من مصلحته [__] هذا التوقيت
الان التوقيت طبعا الشيخ مهم جدا يعني
لابد من
القاء الناظره الى هذا التوقيت مع ذلك
يعني ممكن همم طالما هي جهه همم
جهه قام طبعا عمليه ارهابيه مهما كانت
من قام بها طبعا هذا يعتب هذه تعتبر هذه
عمليات تعتبر عمليات ارهابيه يعني لا اكثر
ولا اقل انا مواجهه طبعا المدنيين ولا
يعني ممكن ان نقول ذنب المدنيين موجود
هناك همم عن ارادتهم يعني قد قتلوا هذه
النقطه الاولى نقطه ثانيه يعني ممكن ان
اقول
يعني احد يعني احد احتمالات اييه هو قد
تكون
مثلا عناصر داعش لماذا
لان يعني في فتره الاخيره يعني هالطاشه
الاخيره قامت يعني قوات الامن تركيا
والشرطه بعمليات كثيره جدا
بعد الزعماء داعش موجودين متخافيين في
تركيا
[موسيقى]
تقوم بعمليه طبعا تجنيد مره اخرى
اكثر من 10 عمليات بعتقد تمت من خلال
الاعتقالها تقريبا
80 او 100 شخص
اكثر صحيح
الاخر يتحدث عن جهه اخرى قد تكون حزب
العمال الكردستاني قد تكون
طرح احد الصحفيين
لصفحه لاغولان قد يكون الاخوان قد يكونوا
يعني جمله اخرى هذا تستثنيه حضرتك
لا اعتقد انه عناصر من العناصر جمعته فتح
الله ولكن قد تكون قد تكون يعني عناصر
فقط انه عناصر مدنيه او لا يقومون
بعمليه من هذا القبيل ولكن معروف من دون
من المؤيدين من عناصر فتح الله كلها هناك
في عسكريين هناك في يعني هناك عناصر امنيه
يعني سابقا طبعا عناصر تدرب وعلى طبعا
تفكيره وعمليات التفجير وكذا فن التفكير
هذا احتمال ممكن نقول احتمال ثاني
همم من جماعه
الجهاديه موجوده في همم شمال سوريا
عناصر حتى بعد الجماعات تنظيمات التي
اعترت على سياسه التركي
هل تريد ان همم تعمل او همم تقيموا
الاتصالات مع قوه الخارجيه او الدول
الخارجيه والجهه الخارجيه وهذا طبعا هددت
هذه العناصر او يعني
عناصر من خلال بعض الناس
قد تكون حركه المسلحه الكرديه قد تقوم
بهذا همم هذا السبب اني انا معروف انه
تركيا يعني همم تستمر في عمليتها صوان في
الشمال العراق في منطقه كرديه ومن العراق
ومن اسوان في منطقه الشماليه كرديه ايضا
من سوريا قد تكون اللي انا سبقت ايضا لهذه
الحركه مره انه قامت بعمليه خلال ثلاثه
يعني همم
ممكن يعني يكون نسائيه في مدينه مارسيل
يعني دي اربع احتمالات ممكن نحن نقول انه
لا لا اركز على جهه واحده
تكمل التحقيقات لاكيد هناك تحقيقات همم
نفهم منها اكثر من المتورط الاساسي في هذه
العمليات حتى يجهز ضيفنا من انقرا الاستاذ
بركات ساكون معك يا استاذ فائق همم جاهز
سانتقل مباشره الى همم انقره مع المحلل
السياسي بركات سيد بركات اهلا بك من جديد
معنا لمحاوله فهم معاشته اسطنبول
والتحديد وتركيا عموما اليوم همم ساتوقف
معك لو سمحت لي مع تصريح للرئيس اردوغان
يقول فيه بان من تسبب في هذه العمليه
الارهابيه كان هدفه هو احاطه تركيا
بالارهاب من كان يقصد
سيد بركات هل تسمعني
رئيسه تركي رجب طيب اردوغان الذي قال فيه
بان من تورط في هذا العمليه الارهابيه
الهدف من هو ابقاء تركيا في دائره الارهاب
فوجدنا ان نفهم هو يتحدث او يشير الى من
بالحقيقه هو يشير طبعا
الاقوى لم يحدد بعد يعني هذه القوى وعندما
سئل حول هل هو عمل ارهابي قلب مبكرا القول
بانه عمل ارهابي لكن استشم يعني بانه
الروائح تدل على ذلك يعني هذا يعني لحتى
الان لم يجد لم يكن هناك اي همم مؤشر همم
معروف تماما او اثبات حول هذه العمليه لكن
العمليه
هي عمليه ارهابيه واضحه بالحقيقه
لا اعلم ان كنت حضرتك شفت الفيديو اللي
فيه وكانه همم في همم على طاوله او على
مقاعد في الشارع في جده الاستقلال وكانه
هناك حقيبه وفيما بعد بلحظات يحدث
الانفجار يعني همم حتى الصوره تؤكد بان
العمليه عمليه ارهابيه
صحيح هذه عمليه ارهابيه اضافه الى ذلك
بانه سمع اطلاق نار من اكثر من طرف
بالحقيقه خلال هذه العمليه لذلك يبدو هناك
في اكثر من عنصر مشارك في هذه العمليه وهي
استهداف بانه همم
وضع الارهاب والرعب في في صفوف الناس كونه
هنا شارع مزدحم دائما معروف بالحقيقه لكن
الرساله واضحه الرساله همم لمن هذه كانت
الرساله هذه لسه غير محدده مين المستفيد
بالاصل من هذه العمليه
المعروف بانه همم
ضمن الشعب بشكل عام هناك بالحقيقه تصور
وانتظار لمن هذه النوع العمليات همم ونحن
ومشرفين على انتخابات بالس القادمه لانه
في ال 2015 حصل ايه نفس العمليات وتم هناك
همم بارباك وارهاب وتفجيرات كثيره بعده
مدن بالحقيقه
كان الهدف منا زعزعه الاستقرار وايقاع
الرعب في صفوف الناس
وابعادها عن
الانتخابات كان في وقتها لانه الانتخابات
الاولى بالحقيقه لم تكن لصالح السلطه
ومحاوله التشويش على هذه الانتخابات على
نقطه قبل الاسترسال في الكلام حظرتك تحدثت
عن انه هناك مؤشرات على تبادل لاطلاق نار
هذا ما همم قلته وبالتالي ان صدقه هذا
القول فنحن في اطار مجموعه وليس فرد واحد
هو الذي همم وضع هذه الحقيبه في هذا
المكان حتى تنفجر حتى يسقط اكبر عدد من
الضح في هذا
الشارع المهم
صحيح صحيح لانه هناك في اشارات بانه اوليه
اللي اتت على اللسان المحافظ بانه من
يعني المؤكد بان هناك في امراه قامت بوضع
العبوا الناسفه لكن اا ممم لماذا تم
الاطلاق النار يعني في نفس الوقت هذا كمان
همم اشاره استفهام بالحقيقه بهذه الامر
ووقوع الضحايا بهذه القدر ليس همم عمليه
بسيطه يعني الامر حتى لو كانت عبوه ناسفه
يعني لذلك همم نتمنى ان لا تكون هذه
العمليه
بانهم مؤشر او بدايه لما حصل في 2015
وتكرار هذه السناديو التي وضعت بوقتها
استاذ بركات منذ قليل بدانا مع الاستاذ
سائق وهو يرجح ان تكون داعش من بين كل
الاطراف التي يمكن ان تكون متهمه او
مستفيده من هذه العمليات الارهابيه يريح
ان تكون داعش هي المستفيده الاكبر بحضرتك
هل توافقه في هذا الطرح
انا بالحقيقه اوافق بهذا الطرح لانه داعش
الان يعني كما المعروف بين فتره واخرى
بالنتيجه المداهمات التي تحصل في بعض
المدن يتم القبض لعشيرات الدعشريين
وهذا مؤشر بانه همم عناصر داعش منتشره
بتركيا وهم بخلايا نائمه لا يعرف متى ان
تتحرك وتنتقم
وبقرار من من اين تاتي يعني همم اكيد
وخارجيه او داخليه حتى الان لكن المعروف
بانه نتيجه هذه الحرب والنتيجه المرور
التي تم بالسنوات السابقه من هذه البلد
الى الى بلدان اخرى لسوريا خاصه وعلى
العراق وغيرها بالحقيقه همم في همم
مخاوف كبيره بانها ممكن ان تقوم انتقام او
على الاقل تحرك هذه القوى من قبل همم قوى
خارجيه همم لاغراض همم يعني لمصلحه طبعا
مختل لما صالح مختلفه
هو هو استاذ بركات فقط عطفا على كلام
حضرتك سيقول البعض ابحث عن السبب لفهم همم
او ابحث عن المستفيد في الواقع همم اللي
فهمم من يمكن ان يكون المتهم ولكن اسمح لي
ان انقل همم هذا التساؤل استاذ سائق كذلك
استاذ فائق همم اذا بحثنا عن المستفيد او
على الاقل عن الروابط السياسيه التي يمكن
ان تعيشها تركيا في هذه المرحله القادمه
في المستقبل المتوسط او القريب هناك
فان ذهبنا في امكانيه ان نتحدث عن داعش ما
مصلحه داعش من الانتخابات هناك ملف شمال
سوريا مهم
همم فما مصلحه داعش همم من همم ملف شمال
سوريا كملف همم تتقاطع فيه اطراف عديده
دوليه واقليميه
ااااه على كل حال يعني بالنسبه لهذه
العناصر او بتنظيمات الصناعي كانت جهاديه
وغير جهاديه فهمم ممكن انا كنت ارهابيه
في فتره الحاليه يعني هدف ليس فقط انه
يعني انت تستفيد من هذه الامور في تركيا
التقرير السلطه التركيه اذا كانت ذلك
تقريبا
في شمال سوريا تضغط على بعض الجماعات
الجهاديه وبعد شهدان
ولكن انتقاميه ولكن
مستفيد الاول واخر سلطه الحليب من هذه
العماليه يعني هذه النقطه مهمه اذا
انطلقنا من انطلقنا من نظريه المؤامره
ممكن ان تكون الايدي الخافيه موجوده داخل
تركيا يعني تعمل هذا عمليه التحريات يعني
ممكن انك نقول همم التحريضيه كبيره جدا
لاثاره البلبله اكثر واكثر على ان تركي
انا حكومه الحاليه هي مهدده من قبل
الارهاب وبالتالي هذه القوه الخارجيه تدعم
هذه الارهاب وبالتالي تخرب تركيا
لابد جماهير تركيا ان تقف معنا الى جانبنا
يعني هذه لان هذه في سوابق لهذه السلطه
استفادت استفادت سابقا كما تفضل همم
استفاده كثيرا جدا هذه السلطه من عمليه
ارهابيه كهذه يعني منطقه سوريا
ايها الجماهير انتم مهددوا بالتالي ان نحن
يعني نحن عمال واحدين لكم نحن ندافع عنكم
وعن مصالحكم وابتالي مستفيدا الوحيد في
فتره لحالي اسطوانه هذه التنظيم او هذه
تلك الجهه ولكن مستفد الواحد باعتقد
السلطه حاليا لانه سوف تروج الاقوال
الدعائيه تقول انه نحن نحن مع استقرار
والان واا
تشديد الامن هو لصالحنا ولا لصالح جماهير
وبالتالي صوتوا يعني لصالحنا وقفوا معنا
يعني هذه نقطه الاساسيه انا بعتقد يعني
هذه العمليه السلام الداخليه التركي على
كل كانت هذه مصفحه اولى اكيد باننا سنعود
لمتابعه همم كل هذه الا تفاصيل لما ترشح
اكثر همم
همم نتائج نتائج التحقيقات اتحدث ولكن
سنكتفي معكم بهذا القدره وشكركم جزيل
الشكر من انقر المحلل السياسي بركه قاره
ومن اسطنبول فائق بلوط المحلله السياسي
شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]